So you have worked hard,
designed, developed,
and launched your awesome app.
The press received
it enthusiastically.
Millions of users downloaded it.
Things were looking really,
really, really good.
Congratulations.
But after a few
weeks, tumbleweeds.
Nothing is going on.
New users do not come back.
Many people install your app
and then forgot about it.
That is very sad.
Let me ask you a question.
Is your app in the Google index?
No?
Then you probably don't know
that app indexing can help you.
Let me show you how.
It was a lazy Sunday afternoon,
and all I wanted to do
is relax.
Japanese cuisine is my
go-to for comfort food.
Soba would be great right now.
So I looked for a recipe
I had once in Japan.
OK, Google.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
I found the recipe online
and launched my favorite app
using the deep link provided
through app indexing.
Yep, I think I have
all the ingredients.
For dessert, I decided
to make some cheesecake.
Lets follow the app
indexing deep link.
Mm, looks delicious.
After that, it was
time to relax and read.
Just the other day,
my friend Lawrence
told me about the book he wrote.
Let me check the book
reviews on Goodreads.
Pretty good.
I started reading the book,
and the action took me
to the city of Las Vegas.
My mind started drifting.
Las Vegas sounds
like a fun city.
Silicon Valley is getting
kind of stressful and pricey.
I wondered, what's the cost
of living in Las Vegas?
Let's find a real estate app.
I started to research
housing, and it
looked quite encouraging.
I could start with
a fixer upper,
but I'm not much of a handyman.
Let's look up handyman
services in Las Vegas.
Yep, I'm set there.
Things look promising.
Since I'm a bit of
a foodie, I really
needed to check the
restaurant scene.
My favorite food in my new
favorite city looks great.
But what's the name
of the review I liked?
Raku, yep, that's the one.
I like how indexing API
enables auto completion, which
saves me from typing.
Whether I am researching
restaurant or music events,
I can quickly get back into the
proper view of the right app
directly from Google Search.
Wow, this was fun.
In this story, I
discovered a new app
and reengaged with several
previously installed apps.
There are over 1 million
apps in Google Play.
More and more of them
are in the Google index,
which enables better app
discovery and higher user
engagement.
It is easy to get your
app in the Google index.
First of all, update
the Android Manifest
of your app to get ready
for receiving intents
from Google Search.
Next, include calls to the App
Indexing API in your activity
implementation.
This will help to get the user
back into the right activity
directly from Google Search.
If you have a website, verify
it in the Google Play Developer
Console.
App indexing can help
drive usage of your app
and improve user
engagement through Google.
Is your app in the index yet?
If not, try this
hands-on tutorial.
You are only a few
steps away from helping
your users gracefully
navigate the web of apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]